wir werden in stoffe brauchen über den
sommer hinaus sicher gelegentlich die
frage warum bestellt ja eigentlich noch
impfstoffe wenn im sommer alle das
impfangebot erhalten haben soll
ja aber wir wissen stand heute nicht
noch nicht ob es auffrischimpfung
braucht wie bei anderen impfungen auch
möglicherweise nach einem jahr zwei
jahren fünf jahren gewissen ist noch
nicht man ein booster braucht eine
verstärkung eine auffrischung der
impfung und zum zweiten kann es möglich
werden durch mutationen die wir heute
noch nicht absehen weil das ein
impfstoff auch angepasst werden muss
verändert werden muss und gerade die mrt
technologie macht es ist möglich dass
auch relativ zügig und gut machen zu
können und deswegen ist es aus meiner
sicht sehr sehr wichtig dass wir ja
heute auch auf dem impfgipfel und mit
den unternehmen auch in beiden ihr
vertretet und schauen was kurzfristig
schneller gehen kann
in vielen bereichen dass wir
gleichzeitig aber eben auch darüber
hinaus produktionskapazitäten in
deutschland und europa sichern und
vorsorglich auch sichern und deswegen
wollen und werden wir auch als grund
entweder über europa wenn die kollegen
in europäischen union das so sehen wie
wir oder sonst national für auch 2022
bereits dosen sichern bestellungen
vornehmen eben vor allem auch bei
produzenten hier in europa um das zu
sichern